this is the grand finale of our 25th
anniversary celebration tomorrow we
start on our second quarter century
actually we kind of already started
it's been a pleasure we've had a lot of
fun here in Chapman I want to just
remind you that you should look at the
Miami Book Fair website WWE Book Fair
calm to find out our dates for next year
put them in your planner your phone
which you should be turning off as I'm
talking put them anywhere on your canoe
calendar however you mark your reminders
and make your reservations if you fly
from out of town and I know people do
are the sisters here this year the three
sister there they are come from all
different parts of the country get
together for Book Fair thank you and
welcome we have a wonderful group from
the west coast of Florida we had people
fly in from Chicago just and there they
are back there and they came and they
look like tourists like in shorts and
sleeveless and scoop-neck and oh it's
wonderful and then some of us come from
Brickell Avenue and Pine Crest and all
over Hollywood right and we hope you'll
all come back next year mark your dates
the other thing is notice our sponsors
when you make your pledge for public
radio or public TV say oh and thank you
for sponsoring Miami Book Fair and when
you go to another festival where Bustelo
or if you're involved in an organization
where one of these corporations is also
a sponsor thank them for helping you and
for helping Miami Book Fair and think
warm and wonderful thoughts about our
biggest sponsor person personality
miami-dade College and dr. Eduardo
Padron
I do want to introduce to you and I'm
not sure which one is going to come out
but they'll introduce the other person
to people who make it happen oh they're
gonna come together Alena and teri on
the executive director of the Florida
center for the literary arts and
Mitchell Katherine
you know we just we just wanted to come
out because this has been such a
remarkable book Fair this year and we
know that it couldn't be anything
without the support about this
incredible Miami audience an audience of
book lovers so both of us want to thank
you for making our 25th the most
remarkable anniversary it could be so
give yourselves a big and you know as
I'm out here a bunch and you know I
represent the Board of Directors but
really Alena who is with the Florida
center of literary arts with her
remarkable team is truly responsible for
all the wonderful organization and
spirit and everything behind this so I
want to personally thank Alina as well
and the Florida center for literary arts
in this entire College for giving us
this gift of the Book Fair and it is our
pleasure to give this gift to the
community year after year and on behalf
of dr. Eduardo Padron as Barbara said
who really was one of the visionary
individuals who got the ball rolling 25
years ago I want to thank you all for
your support and want to tell you to
mark your calendars again
November 8th to the 15th next year and
we hope to see you then
thank you for your support
so that's the 8th through the 15th
that's it Thank You Elena you can become
a friend and sign up fast so you can
reserve your space for them you know the
other thing we do and what we've done
this year is work very closely with
other national organizations some of you
might have been to the cities of refuge
event on Friday night there was a
remarkable event yesterday as well that
Penn America put on and this event this
afternoon we're also doing in
conjunction with Penn to and to
introduce our guests it's my pleasure
and honor to bring up someone whom I've
admired for a very long time she does
this remarkable festival up in New York
and all you festival goers should find
out about it to make sure you go up
there it's the panworld voices festival
in New York City and her name is Carol
Llewellyn please give her a warm warm
why anyway
well hello and welcome and it's amazing
to see close to 700 people here tonight
on a Sunday evening it restores your
faith in the world it was restored last
Tuesday I think with Barack Obama it's
restored again new tonight
well as Mitch said my name is Karen
Llewellyn and I am the artistic director
of the Penn Wood Voices festival of
international literature in New York
which means that one of the people who
is about to come out on stage is
actually my bus which makes me more
nervous than ever
anyway it's wonderful to see so many of
you here this evening and surely there
is no better way to cap off what has
been an extraordinary feast of
literature here in Miami than with the
very two special guests who are about to
join us but before I introduce you to
them I would just like to say and to
really take my hat off to
Mitchell and the entire team here at the
Miami Book Fair it's been an
extraordinarily rich feast of literature
and I'd like to say Bravo to them
who on earth said the book was dead and
I'm very happy to say that it's not just
Miami that loves to make a literary
splash each spring pen also whips up a
literary feast where we bring more than
150 writers from around the globe to New
York City to talk about their work their
ideas their lives our focus is
particularly international and at this
year's festival we represented 51
countries and some 23 different
languages part of our mission and our
goal is to raise the number of books
published from translation in this
country from the appalling figure of
less than 3% to something better in line
with countries in Europe where more like
30 to 40 percent of books originated
from translation how on earth can you
know the world and understand its people
if you never read their books so please
if you love literature which you all
clearly do because you are here and this
is another date for your diary it's
gonna be a busy literary of the year for
you all next year mark the dates April
29th through May 3 and your diaries to
join us in New York for the fifth
edition of pan world voices it's a big
birthday for us not quite 25 but we will
get there and we'll be celebrating with
an extraordinary lineup of the best
literary voices from all corners of the
globe but tonight it is my great
pleasure and honor to introduce our
guest Salman Rushdie and Nathan
Englander Nathan Englander was born in
New York in 1970 his short fiction has
appeared in The Atlantic Monthly The New
Yorker and numerous anthologies
including the best American short
stories the O'Henry prize anthology and
the Pushcart prize Ingrid is Englanders
short story story collection for the
relief of unbearable urges earned him a
pen Malamud Award and the Academy of
American Academy of Arts and Letters sue
Calculon price of his book about the
ministry of special cases the New York
Times Book Review said who is this
Nathan Englander so young in novelist
years but already possessed of an old
masters voice one reads this novel in or
of England is
the Seattle Times called it a tour de
force a few pages into the Ministry of
special cases it becomes clear how much
Englander has to bring to the topic
pitch-black humour a skeptical affection
for his characters and the narrative
ability to trace the impact of fascism
with the modern face on a cluster of
lives he was a Guggenheim Fellow in 2003
and a fellow at the Dorothy and B Lewis
common center for scholars and writers
at the New York Public Library in 2004
Salman Rushdie is the author of 10
novels including Midnight's Children
which was awarded the Booker Prize and
the Booker of Booker's for the Best
novel to him won the prize in its first
25 years he's also the author of shame
The Satanic Verses the Moors last sigh
the ground beneath her feet fury
Shalimar the clown and most recently The
Enchantress of Florence the subject of
course of tonight's conversation and a
book Joyce Carol Oates said in the New
York Review of Books
this is history jubilantly mixed with
post modernist magic realism while the
Chicago Tribune called it a baroque
whirlwind of a narrative and said
Rushdie helps us escape from the present
into a dreamlike past that ultimately
makes us more aware of the dangers and
illusions of our everyday lives Salman
is also the author of a book of stories
east-west and three works of nonfiction
he's the editor of marowak and anthology
of contemporary Indian writing and has
adapted Midnight's Children for the
stage a fellow of the British Royal
Society of literature and a member of
the American Academy of Arts and Letters
Salman Rushdie has received so many
awards that if I were to list them all
here tonight I'll be here for hours so
I'm just going to give you the little
abridged version and but here's honors
include the Whitbread prize for best
novel which he won twice the Writers
Guild Award the James Tait black prized
the budapest grand prize for literature
the austrian state prize for european
literature and the london international
writers award he has received the
freedom of the city in mexico city
strasbourg and el paso and the Edgerton
prize of the American Civil Liberties
Union
he holds the rank of commander in the
order of Arts and Letters
highest artistic honour between 2004 and
2006 he served as president of Pan
American Center and continues to work as
the chair of the panel of voices
festival which he created five years ago
in 2007 he received a knighthood in the
Queen's Birthday Honours his books have
been translated into over 40 languages
and I have to say
he is the best boss ever you are in for
a treat this evening ladies and
gentlemen and please mate welcome summer
Rushdie and Nathan England
good to go
yeah it's about lists yeah I'm gonna ask
Salman questions for a while
45 minutes that we're gonna take
questions from the audience unless he
hates my questions then we'll take a lot
of questions from the audience so yeah
here we go I accepted the invitation is
for two reasons because I'm a big fan of
Salman and I'm also a huge fan of this
new novel
I like when writers get better and
better and also because when I get to
see you around it's just I grew up and
got to be a writer it is really
unsophisticated to torture at parties so
I get to ask all the questions that I
would never bother you and socially
thank you I mean I I once did that for
that exact reason I did it with Toni
Morrison because because you know you
didn't want to bother her at parties you
know and she once was being interviewed
on television in England and she wanted
somebody she knew to do the interview
and I could have jumped at it because
then I could ask her all the questions I
never ever asked her so your turn here I
go so yeah I do love this book within
the first 20 pages of this book there's
a wondrous city a pirate ship a draw
it's a drawn sword and even scarier
drawn penis of impressive proportions
drugging and drowning and this is again
by page 20 when I said that's right I
think you don't want to write books that
can be written and I always talk about
executing the unexcusable and this book
in a sense shouldn't be able to be
written it's structurally crazy but it's
oddly not crazy because aside from all
the stories in it it's a story basically
in a sense you're writing the history of
history or the story of story that's a
major part of this book and I just was
wondering when you set out to write this
book if you knew really how giant it was
gonna get nope I didn't I mean I thought
it was gonna be a really simple little
romance I mean you know historical
romance but it doesn't didn't work out
like that but I think you see originally
I had thought that the story of the the
story that's in the story the story that
is told by the storyteller who arrives
in India to tell the story that story
inside the story about the lost
MacGuffin
who gets captured and passed around the
world like a parcel and eventually ends
up in Renaissance Europe and falls in
love with this guy and I thought I
thought that was going to be the whole
novel and that it would be very simple
tale of this girl's adventure and it
just wasn't interesting enough it felt
like there was things missing and and
when I then thought that if I start
later with a mystery where this young
man arrives in the court of the great
Mughal emperor Akbar claiming to be his
relative
you know claiming to be the descendants
of this lost princess and you don't know
if he's making the whole thing up or
lying and and and you know he can't
prove it I mean there's no DNA test he
doesn't have any kind of special signet
ring or any identifying mark all he has
is the story and whether he can sell the
story you know to the Emperor at that
point I began to find it worked you know
so it did become a story about the
telling of a story and about the power
that stories have over us and so on but
that really wasn't that was a discovery
in the making of the book rather than
anything to do with the original idea I
guess on that no I just don't know what
you believe personally because I just
lately been thinking there are multiple
realities and multiple truths in the
world this book is very much saying in a
sense that you know history does get
written that truth you know can be
written after the fact I mean yeah I
mean I you know I studied history it was
my subject that at university and one of
the things you the moment you do that
one of the first things you learn is
that history is is a construct you know
and that it there's no such thing as
just objective history you know each age
retells the story of the past according
to its own interests you know if you
look at the way in which the sixteenth
century was written about in the 17th
century and then in the 18th of the 19th
or 20th it's completely different might
be a different century
because we see in the past the things
that we want to see and we want that we
want to discuss so it's very difficult
to arrive at any kind of I mean of
course there are objective facts you
know we know that certain people lived
and died and ruled and were deposed and
behaved well or badly and of course
there are those things but the meaning
of history it's the very shifting thing
it's as long as you're answering your
studies we have a I think we both love
Yvonne navikev dearly because of him I
have the fr leavis I have the great
tradition on my night table but you also
you studied history but it's sort of I
feel like you unstudied English at
University yeah
reverse effect on you I I my one of my
pieces of great good fortune is that I
have never studied English literature
you know I mean as a result I did not
become a critic you know I've always
thought you know in Waiting for Godot
when Vladimir and Estragon are insulting
each other and the insults get ruder and
ruder and ruder the ultimate insult is
critic that's what you get with a
history degree with an English degree
Livas was there you know when I was at
Cambridge Livas was still there and I
actually did hear him and you know he
was a brilliant lecturer and I think the
the problem was the problem with the
great tradition is then it's just leave
us his opinion and it's and then he
tried to impose it I mean I'm not such a
big fan of D H Lawrence for example and
also they're all white you know and one
of the things that I think is
interesting about what's happened in the
literature of the English language is
the way in which it's become a world
literature the way that you have
Caribbean literature and African
literature and Australian literature and
of course many different kinds of
American English is and Irish literature
and so on so the problem with the great
tradition is that it was trying to hold
on to an idea a canonical idea of
England yeah you know and I'm not
interested in that about languages then
I'll bring you - word and we'll go from
that there's a word which we like my
family which is
beginning like people who can't allow
you to have a good thing that you
deserved you know they just can't give
you credit yeah but even my friends like
readers who just can't forget in
anything they support what you did with
Midnight's Children even my biggest sour
puss reader friends but uh but it's
about language I want to talk about that
I speak Keeper in English and speak a
good he blush and a good English and I
guess I wanted to talk to you about
English and Bombay and I mean you
basically introduced a new or not a new
English that's they're exactly the idea
of me coming from my Long Island Western
head but that idea trusting the reader
to be able to read a world that is
different but you know I read but
American Jewish literature Sid Roth for
example and you'd have all these sort of
Yiddish sprinkled in it completely
unexplained you know I mean I remember
reading I don't know if it's Portnoy or
whatever it is where somebody gets a
zetz in the kishkas you know and I'm
thinking Zets kishkas to have to explain
that to Miami audience I don't think so
but so eventually I thought well if he
could do it I could do it you know if he
could have zetz is in the kicker's that
I can have words borrowed from other
languages and I mean you've got to make
it clear from context you've got to make
it clear whether it's something to eat
or a swear word or but but they are that
you can you can it's just flavoring
right but what I thought was that you
see if you grow up as I did in a city
like Bombay everybody is multilingual I
mean everybody because otherwise you
can't talk to anyone you know I mean
Bombay for instance my mother Thomas
will do I went to an English medium
school the national language is Hindi
that the two main regional languages are
Gujarati and Marathi so there's at least
five you know and then there's more and
what people actually speak is a is a an
agro which is none of those languages we
do all of them mixed up and what I
thought I wanted to do was to find a way
to make English sound like that you know
I mean obviously you can't really do it
because in the book is written in five
languages and
nobody can read it and that would not be
good but to give that that sense of play
linguistic play you know and that's
where I started out yeah I ended up
writing a doctoral thesis instead of
questions but I've cut it down but I
have 9,000 questions about your Akhbar
which is just fascinating to me but I
guess that's I just want to know you
know you speak so I've read a bunch of
interviews you did about this book and
you speak so lovingly it's really sweet
about Akbar I feel like you've really
come to love him and I'm wondering if
you still separate the historical Akbar
versus your Akbar if they're conflict
I mean yeah you know the thing with out
where is that you if you grow up in the
Indian educational system you get taught
the Mughal Empire whether you like it or
not and and and to an extent you you've
come to be sick of it you know and you
have to sort of recover from that
but I've always carried around with me
the memory of this extraordinary king
who is not entirely lovable you know
because there's a side of him that is he
was a despot but he was an absolute
ruler and he did you know if you didn't
like him if he didn't like you he would
throw you off the top of a building you
know and then if you didn't die he'd
throw you off the top of the building
again but headfirst this time make sure
he does she did that to somebody um so
there's but the other side of him I mean
remember this is a man who is the direct
linear descendant of Genghis Khan and
Tamburlaine you know so in his entire
bloodline is savage brutal warlordism
and he himself had the most turbulent
early life he was abandoned on a
battlefield by his father and he was
brought up by relatives who didn't like
him and often wanted to kill him and he
was illiterate and you know then he
actually came ascended to the throne
when he was only 15 years old and and
and how would a man like that end up
deciding to be in favor of peace and
tolerance and openness and multiplicity
and could and and and you know
bringing people together rather than
crushing them and etc you know jenga's
con when he didn't like you he would he
would have a wooden floor put on top of
you and he'd sit on top of you and eat
his dinner and crush you so he wasn't
the man the thing that the miracle of my
Akbar is that a man with that background
should turn into a man like this and and
he's that makes him interesting well
sort of about his let's call it his
softer side then I think you're much
better atheist I'm sort of a Woody Allen
failed atheist but I feel like you sir I
don't know if I can call it secular
humanism but in this book I love the
water drinkers and the wine drinkers
enough you want to talk about that but
is it basically humanism that he's
creating it was a kind of Indian proto
humanism yes I mean he was a I suppose
he was a kind of old-fashioned pantheist
he believed that all religions were
essentially a way of worshipping the
same garden and that therefore there
should be no distinction made between
them you don't say this one's better and
that one's worse you know they're just
all different and he did set up this
debating chamber where all these ideas
could be constantly debated in fact you
know the Portuguese had just started
their little colony in Goa
at that time so that was the first like
little European foothold in India was
Goa and and he sent a message to the
Portuguese in Goa and said would they
please send their two best arguers up to
the court because he wanted them to
argue with his guys and so these two
Jesuits arrived at the at the mughal
court and and stayed there for sir like
twelve years so I guess there was a lot
of arguing to do and and the thing about
the water drinkers of the wine drinkers
I've been actually that's there were
these two parties you know like the like
the Republicans and the Democrats you
know of the blue golf court what they
were called the water drinkers of the
wine drinkers and the water drinkers as
you can imagine were sort of puritanical
and humorless and you know Republican
and the wine drinkers were having lots
of fun and drinking wine and having
laughs and being very enjoyable and you
know they were the good guys
um but that debating chamber was at the
heart of his court that that idea that
the idea that all ideas should be
constantly argued out that was something
very new and certainly very new for an
absolute ruler you introduced and was
something like the beginning of an open
society yeah well you make him a really
sweet thing it's when he looks and he
sees the building the house of scandal
burning and he thinks maybe he started
it with his thoughts it's such a sweet
moment of a man trapped by power I don't
know I thought yes you're right I mean
right whether he was really so cuddly or
whether that's my you know well again
you know what then I'll come back to
awkward but I want to then jump to your
Machiavelli speaking of cuddly like we
all know Prince Machiavelli and how we
think of him in a certain way you sort
of in your version if you're doing
Republicans and Democrats I sort of
think it's like if Al Gore went home in
2004 eight years and was writing about
how angry he was and then he became this
horrible angry cute creature in history
you've made him like this yeah no I
think I mean I felt I'm very fond of
Machiavelli always have been ever since
I first discovered him when I was you
know when I was a history student when I
was 20 years old I when I went to
Florence for a summer vacation when I
was 20 and and because I would obviously
there's all this wonderful art and
architecture but but because I was a
history student I also became very
interested in the people and the thing I
thought about Machiavelli is is that
he's been very unfairly treated by
history because his name conjures up all
this you know cynicism and ruthlessness
and blah blah because of the because of
that little book the Prince wears
actually the truth is that Machiavelli
was not Machiavellian
and I mean if you think about him he was
somebody who when he served the people
of Florence
it was actually when when it was a
republic when they threw the Medicis out
and he was very much you know in the old
sense the word Republican I mean he was
a believer in a republic not in Princes
no and when the when the people of
Florence ratted on him and brought the
Medicis back
they didn't the Medicis didn't like it
either and they tortured him and tried
to kill him and eventually didn't and
exiled him this was not a man with any
reason to love that kind of prince you
know but what he was was somebody who
saw around him the behavior of these
appalling families you know the Medicis
the Borgia as the sport says the great
families of their nation was how cruel
they were you know if they didn't like
the bishop they'd hang him outside the
window at full regalia by the neck not
good for the bishop at you know they
would poison people knife people kill
people you know and this was happening
every day in every Italian city-state
and he was looking at it and so he ended
up in exile defeated broken almost
writing this very dark little book about
the nature of power and basically it's
he's writing about what he had seen and
indeed what had happened to him you know
and then he got blamed for it and and
actually like so many things it's
essentially the fault of the French this
is because in the 17th century about a
hundred years after of ocularly there
was this book written in France called
the ante machiavel which was the book
which essentially demonized him and that
it's that view that has been followed
ever since but actually he was this you
know he was the life and soul of the
party there's this wonderful letter to
him from a friend when he's away on
business saying would you please come
back quickly because when you're not
here there's nobody to organize the fun
that's you know he wrote the biggest the
most popular comedy of the Renaissance
the mandragora the Mandrake root was the
big smash hit comedy of the 16th century
so he was in many ways very attractive
person and I just felt that I wanted to
you know salvage the real Machiavelli
from underneath this I guess it makes me
jump do you think I mean you've spent
it'll be the 30th anniversary of
Midnight's Children soon and yeah anyway
thanks thanks youthful just worked out
that what I published my first book he
was 5 years old but I read it and I
guess yeah you know just talking about
somebody's reality being made from the
outside and yes you've spent so much of
your time I'll put a photo on the font
what today but um but even you know even
this idea that you know Gandhi came
after you you know in there in theory
yes yes but but sort of this idea you
spend so much of your life in the public
eye and is especially in the tabloids I
it's true that I was as I said I was
interested in in in these aspects of
Machiavelli long before anybody had a go
at me but it's true that I've since then
become familiar with what it's like to
be demonized what it's like to be sort
of publicly falsified you know and I
suppose that did increase my interest in
writing this advising that writing about
that aspect you know of what happened to
to Machiavelli over maybe four hundred
years from now somebody will write a
book about me yeah takes about four
hundred years it took they took the Pope
400 years to admit that Galileo was
right it does go right so 400 years from
Islamic radicals will go God we were
wrong yes
exactly I have a million more questions
about the book but this one is sort of
where the book breaks its boundaries
it's a lot of stories within stories and
I just don't want to run out of time for
this one because I love I was raised by
a TV set I love the pop culture so they
were listening all your credits and
honors and your knighthood and they left
out my favorite part which is you have
your own u2 song but there's I think I'm
right in saying that I am the only
person other than mr. Hewson who has
ever written the lyrics for a u2 song
yes because he writes all the others I
was gonna say it was that first but
there's another song that you mentioned
that I was really just personally dying
to ask you about I'll read from the book
if she was a Florin I would have spent
her and if she was a book than I would
have lent her if she was a bow then I
would have bent her and if she was a
courtesan then I would rent her my sweet
polenta in the acknowledgments of this
book which is just too tasty to pass up
you mentioned that you wrote this song
with Ian McEwan and I guess I was
wondering if you'd and and I had dinner
in some Italian restaurant probably had
slightly too much to drink and there was
on the menu something called sweet
polenta yeah
so we imagined her to be a girl
essentially wrote I mean I can't even
remember who wrote which lines but just
this series of hypotheses you know if
she was offended than I would dent her
if she didn't exist I would invent her
if she was a meaning I would have meant
her you know my sweet polenta like that
so um and and I I mean I used one or two
of those in the book and I just thought
I'd better politely let McEwan helped a
bit so it's a novel by Salman Rushdie
with additional dialogue but you and
McEwan wenn das romp the painter in the
book enters his own painting Akbar says
accepting that basically creativity can
work in both directions that the border
is crossable between the imagines and
that really says a dream
could become his dream and I feel like
like your wine drinkers and your water
drinkers I feel like this book is your
personal exploration of the idea that
reality and imagination shouldn't be so
at odds I feel like you're trying to
make peace with the imagination or
something yeah I think so there's a
somebody there's a line somewhere in the
book which says that this was a period
in which the real and the fantastic had
not yet separated into different to live
under different legal systems you know
that they were all a part of the same
thing and and what I meant by that first
of all that this was a period in the
east and the west and everywhere in
between
where people profoundly believed in
magic I mean they actually believed in
magic the way we would now believe in
science and medicine you know and and
they didn't think of magic as being
something separate from everyday life it
was just an aspect of everyday life and
I came to think that they believed in
magic more seriously than they believed
in religions you know that you could
sort of mess around with religions but
you couldn't disagree about the power of
magic by the occult was a part of the
world you know and I thought that was
wonderfully liberating idea for me to be
able to write the book in which there
was no there was no difference in kind
between what was magical and what was
naturalistic you know that they were the
same kind of thing and I thought what
wonderful I mean how how different it
would be existentially you know to
imagine the world like that and and how
much more impoverished it is really for
us to think of reality is this kind of
prosaic thing that we now do and that
you know our dream lives are imaginative
lives are more fantastic selves are kind
of separated and put into a kind of
kennel in the yard you know and we don't
really think of them as having the same
kind of reality that what we think of as
reality has you know but back then they
did you know and I thought that was
preferable this so every date sometimes
you're asked which century you'd like to
live in if it wasn't now I've always had
a great
a soft spot for the 16th century 16th
century with penicillin with pet Yahoo
exactly that absolutely that there's
novocaine yes no because actually the
big problem is dentistry if you ever
want to live it any century other than
your own don't get sick don't get sick
or else you're dead yes your oranges
I teach sweet polenta there's sweet
Vanessa your assistant was in my class a
while ago but I taught this book which I
love Francis Yates art of memory which
will make your eyes bleed and I don't
think they've recovered and they still
hate me for it but I was so happy to see
in this book I just love ideas of the
memory palace I don't know if you talked
about this idea
oh the memory palette you know I do you
know this man Jaron Lanier even come
across and he said she's the man who
invented virtual reality and well you
know is a very extraordinary kind of
contemporary intelligence and he played
17 medieval musical instruments and he
composes operas and I hate him anyway he
I was talking to him some years ago and
and he was talking about this idea of
the memory palace which I actually
didn't know about at the time the memory
palace is a trick of memory trick which
actually can dates back to ancient
Greece and and basically what it is is
that you imagine a building it doesn't
have to be a palace you know it's gonna
be anywhere but you imagine a place that
you're very very familiar with and that
you know it's you know you could walk
around it in your mind and what you do
is as you walk around in your mind you
attach memories to different objects in
it so that you sit things down on a
bureau or on a chair or you put them on
shelves in a closet and and then as you
afterwards walk around the building and
in your mind and you go to those places
those memories are attached to them and
it's it's a it's actually it's a memory
trick which anyone can use and it really
does work it allows you to remember
gigantic amounts of things and it
started as I say in in the ancient Greek
time of course because in the
Renaissance there was such an interest
in the culture of ancient Greece and
Rome the idea of the memory power
someone revived yeah and so there it was
again means in my book there's a kind of
extreme version of it where there's this
woman who's essentially being
brainwashed I mean they had she's had
her entire memory replaced with somebody
else's memory which has been placed in
the so she's become the memory palace
it's yes so how much could we say about
this me nine hours but I think they're
probably yeah have to find out yeah
happens to what it doesn't end well
yes well since we're gonna there's sex
involved and then there's death is that
is that interesting at all about
anything and that's running out of time
I would feel terrible if we didn't talk
about Yoda and The Enchantress at all
but about the again I hate using the
word experiments because writing is not
a science experiment it's not black and
white if it wasn't and Pathak inhuman
and imbalance then it wouldn't be it
wouldn't live so you know I used the
wrong word when I call it experimental
of this idea of a princess dream
basically you've got the is that wasn't
and there wasn't that is in this book in
a very serious manner the dreams
princess that was and yeah I mean
there's there's all these women the
other that sent partly or largely made
up by other people and who then acquire
a kind of reality of their own you know
kind of autonomy of their own in the way
I think that any of us who write know
that that fictional entities do acquire
you know you first you make them up and
then you can't tell them what to do and
and in the novel there's these two women
one of whom is the supposed queen of the
Emperor of Myrtle but in fact she's a
figment of his imagination and then
there's this other the main actually the
title character who actually who's a
figment of my imagination
who is this lost princess who eventually
comes to obsess
him and in a way replace in his
imagination the woman he made up and
fell in love with you know so and the
thing about her that the title character
is that again there's a the
of historical fact is that that it's
true that the emperor akbar's
grandfather barber not an elephant the
even before he established the empire
when he was just kind of what we would
now call an Afghan warlord and actually
not doing very well being defeated
there's a point where he was besieged in
the city of Samarkand by a rival and he
was told that the price of his survival
and his safe conduct out of the city
would be that he had to surrender his
beautiful sister
he had a famously beautiful sister and
he did so and he was obviously all there
embarrassed about it and in his
autobiography he kind of glosses over it
but she went off with this other guy and
she was with him for 10 years in fact
didn't had children with him and then he
was interned defeated and killed by the
Shah of Persia who wanted good relations
with the Mughals so he sent her home so
in in real life what happened that she
goes home and she lives happily ever
after but I thought well that doesn't
have to happen there could be a more um
interesting outcome and but then I
thought I don't want to mess with actual
history because this woman the sister of
the Emperor Babur was called cansada
Begum she existed we know about her that
story is told it's in the history books
and I thought I don't want to change
that you know I don't want to just say
give her a completely different life
story than the one that you really had
so I thought I'm gonna leave her alone
I'm gonna invent another sister so I
invented a younger sister who is more
badly behaved and doesn't go home when
she's supposed to because she decides
that she fancies the Shah of Persia and
she'd rather stay with him and so in a
way her if you like sexual choices begin
actually move the plot forward because
then she falls in love with an Italian
soldier of fortune and that's how she
ends up in Florence and makes lots of
trouble and and she's probably a witch
yes I was gonna say if they caught
ground beneath her feet as a love
triangle this is like a love round this
eight dimension there is just so much
love crosses really Sabri essentially
it's a love story it's a love story in
the road novel mmm I'm about to eat said
right now about all your research I I
read this as a reader and then I read it
as a writer and doing my homework for
this but just so many modern novels I
feel like it's the siren for the modern
novelist when there's research involved
as you can feel sometimes you're reading
and you feel that somebody has fallen in
love with a fact and it just bumps you
they just had something so good they had
to write it in and I was really happy to
read because you know you balance
everything so beautifully that you
didn't use you know 95 percent oh you
Lisa I think that was or there's a you
know given how rich the history of this
period is it would have been very easy
for this book to be a thousand pages
long a suitable goal but I really from
the very beginning I had a very strong
instinct that it should not be a book
like that that it should not be
encyclopedic you know and I've written
my share of encyclopedic stuff but this
time I thought really I want it to be
this sprightly tail that moves swiftly
through its material and so I told
myself I got you pinned it up on the
wall of my workroom this note saying
only if it serves the story that makes
me happy I love other people with their
yeah only if it serves the story and if
not never mind how interesting it is
right if it doesn't advance the story
it's about yes I know it says don't
watch daytime television you're at work
put your pants on earth there's also
that thing I don't have it anymore but
there's a line which I believe to be a
line of Hemingway's about commitment
somebody asked having wave I'd rather
writers should have commitment and he
said the only commitment a writer needs
is the commitment of the seat of his
pants to the seat of his chair I had a
note of my wall say sit down
you can't write standing up and we're
gonna go to the Orient maybe do you want
to say any about I know you've maybe
used it for other stuff you're the
writing about the Mughal Court paintings
you want to talk about the hunt Sonam or
not at all no not at all let's go to the
audience we have time for questions
all right thank you God very quick PhD
thesis
yeah yeah
yes it's rusty yes you are an author
whose works have been translated into
different languages as well you know
different languages I have you rape joke
works in these different languages and
do they bring across the same a theme or
or what you were trying to say well I
mean it's a great question the question
of our translation because obviously
well I mean I you know my books are
translated into a lot of languages that
I can't but I can't read in a Korean for
example you know you can't even read the
script I have I mean I could read the
French translation and to an extent the
Italian one but I think translation is
one of the great arts you know and and
and one of the least appreciated arts
because in a way it seeks to a face
itself you know that the the the
translation that is best is the one
which gives you the impression that
you're reading the original text you
know and whether translate and whether
translator is somehow invisible you know
I mean that's so it means people often
undervalue the art of translation and I
I've been very fortunate in having a
large number of very exceptional
translators you know and who have worked
for my books for very long periods of
time and I mean they get to know my
books better than I do they will
sometimes say to me you know on page 472
where so-and-so says this well 15 years
ago in this other novel on page 173 you
had another character saying the same
thing at which point you think [ __ ]
and you know only your translator knows
your work this well nobody else ever
does including not you you know so so I
am you know I played great respect to
these translators and as Carole
Llewellyn was saying when she spoke I
mean this the problem of translation and
how bad American publishers are
providing the best of world literature
in English translation is something
which had pen we really fought for you
know to try and get that number up
because simply there are so many of the
world's greatest writers who are not
available to you in this country you
know you can't find out who they are you
know you might have seen their name in
the paper when they win the Nobel Prize
or something you know but very few of
their books I mean take for this year's
winner you know and look plays you as
far as I know there's not a single book
of his in print in this country at the
moment and he's this year's winner of
the Nobel Prize so there is it's a big
problem
we all accept that you know things
change in translation some things are
lost inevitably not you know not
everything is carried across the
language frontier but a lot is in a good
translation you know I read I mean you
know was saying this in this session
today you know tears that you know those
of us who are big readers a lot of what
we read is translation you know I mean I
I mean I I don't read Spanish well
enough to have read Garcia Marquez and
Vargas Llosa and Boris in Spanish I've
only read them in translation and no
doubt there are people reading in the
original who are getting some nuances
that I'm missing but I feel that I'm
getting plenty you know I'm getting a
lot that I want to get you know so I
mean it's it's an imperfect thing but
it's a very very valuable thing um we're
discussing the book Tuesday night I just
finished it just before the program
began let it go hey uh I was wonderful
and and the interesting thing I listened
to I listened to a recorded version for
the first half and then read the second
half and it really was wonderful
listening to it because it's I mean
their stories so it's it's sort of
interesting to listen to it the way you
know stories are told you know
traditionally and I mean there's so many
things I mean our book group has been
going around the world so one of the
reasons I was intrigued by the the
review when I read about the book was
that it combines Florence and India and
the different cultures and everything
and then it went well I I won't talk
tell everyone how it ends up but you
then you reach another part of the world
but anyway I thought it was really
delightful and I was wondering if there
is I've done some research you know
about you and about the book and you
know what people have said about it
is there anything that you would have to
say to our book group about how we
should approach the book or how you know
but what your goals were um what my
goals were I don't I don't know that I
had anything quite as kind of definite
as goals because I say it's it's it's
more to do with discovery then then a
plan you know I just felt that this
period that I was writing about it
everywhere whether it's whether it's in
India or pusher or Ottoman Turkey or
Europe or as you suggested this place
that's just bubbling up on the western
horizon called the new world what you
see is the world that we now live in
just being for essentially we're looking
at the birth of the modern world
you know and and that's true everywhere
it's true in India it's true in the
Ottoman Empire it's true in the
Renaissance and of course it's true in
in the new world no and I thought how
interesting it is sometimes to go back
to the beginning you know it's it's a
way of understanding how the story
turned out you know so so that's why if
I had a plan that was it was to write
this book about the birth of the new
world or the birth of the modern world
you know and and defined how whatever
kind of shaggy-dog story I needed to
find in order to stitch it together
and that she's the shaggy-dog the
autocracy Florence hello I hope you
forgive me for asking a sort of terribly
horrific real-world question but it was
reported by Newsweek that a number of
Pentagon brass generals were warned not
to fly the next day they were scheduled
to fly in September 11th also mayor
Willie Brown was reportedly warned not
to fly and there was this rumor that
there was you were warned not to fly or
come near New York and I wonder if you
could put that to bed or was there any
truth to that
you know I'm sorry to disappoint all
internet paranoiacs they told Salman not
to fly and Jews to stay home it's just
it's just not true
it's you know there are as you know that
9/11 event spawned a whole you know a
zillion crazy internet sites and
unfortunately I got mixed up in some of
them I did call Newsweek about the
Pentagon story and just for the record
they did confirm that story they're
standing behind it they reported it
twice and two separate Newsweek articles
that top Pentagon grant brass were
warned they did not fly and they well I
called Evan Thomas he said yes we're
standing behind that story know what I
mean I'm just telling you about me
appreciate that thank you they were if I
could explain I mean the only
explanation I could give is that there
was a period which had nothing to do
with the 9/11 attack when I did
sometimes have difficulty getting on
airplanes which had to do with the
airplanes reluctance to have me as a
passenger and it had it had absolutely
nothing to do with what happened in New
York and Washington and Pennsylvania so
it may be that simply two stories got
conflated and turned into one story you
know better um I'm happy to say I'm able
to fly now
if we hurry we can do the last two
Avilan all right as someone who has had
a part of our place in your head I
wanted to get
you're feeling on how much of a threat
you still feel as Islamic radicalism
still is and also whether or not you
feel that after eight years of Bush's
bungling on the war on terror we may be
a little bit too - war weary and perhaps
maybe the pendulum is swung a little too
far in the other direction where we are
- willing and - eager to make peace with
people that still want to destroy us
this is a political question ya know I
think you know what I think is I I don't
know how to say this I think the world
just changed and we have to see what the
meaning of that is I think we don't I
mean I do think that I mean I think
probably everyone not just in this
country but around the world feels
excited by the potential unleashed by
the result of the American presidential
election and and and I mean I don't know
how it will work out you know I don't we
don't know what kind of President Barack
Obama will be we just know that it's a
great relief to have come to the end of
a certain period in American history
and I think what it shows me is the
thing that I was arguing a lot of long
time during the worst excesses of
president Cheney's administration which
is that that what was called anti
Americanism which was so prevalent in
much of the last 8 years was in fact not
anti Americanism it was just a dislike
of how the American government was
behaving and you can see in the enormous
waves of positive feeling towards the
United States in the last 10 days or so
the fact that people actually like that
idea of America which they feel they are
now able to rediscover and people are
actually impressed with what America was
able to do in this election which is
something which frankly no Western
European country would have done you
know when you think of France electing a
president with a Muslim middle name know
it's you know it's not conceivable that
England at this moment could elect you
know a non-white prime minister it just
could not happen and so people once
again see America as capable of these
extraordinary acts of transformation and
indeed of leadership and it says it
America people like so what's happened
is the change that's happened now I mean
how did see how that will play out you
know I mean I don't think any of us
quite know that you know but now I got
an email sort of a friend on the other
side saying I hope he brings a blessing
serve I hope you bring some of the
change you believe in well I mean it's
what Barack means you know it means
blessed yes it does enlightening and
both these things are good
we want blessed lightning yes Salman I
was told to be brief Oh be brief yes all
right see yes I'm a big concern of your
criticism in Islam if you have think
that it's anything fraud anything
I think I'm asking you since you were so
critical in Islam if you think is the it
is a fraudulent religion fraudulent yeah
I don't think it's any more fortunate
than any other religion I mean you see I
have I have this view that God does not
exist and that's my view therefore
people pushing the other line I don't I
mean I find it to be unconvincing and no
of course not fraud it's the wrong kind
of word to use you know I mean I what I
think is that a kind of puritanical
intolerance has taken hold of a lot of
the Islamic world which is at odds with
much of the history of Islam itself and
Islam in my lifetime in many places in
the world has been not like that no and
I mean I'm my family's from Kashmir and
Kashmiri Islam was not like this you
know there's this this the thing that we
call Islam which is essentially what
some of the oil money is and Iranian
revolutionaries have foisted on the
world so now I mean I have I mean I have
a particular reason to be pissed off
with Muslims but not all Muslims you
know only the ones who tried to kill me
the last question and then we're good to
go
I'm a great admirer of Solomon and my
question was I don't know how briefed
you can be but I was just imagining how
do you come up with these ideas when you
write I mean do you just go to Fateh
oppositely and you know think after
walking down or you know Yoda by walking
down or you know how how do you create
there's a there's a shop that we those
of us who have the secret handshake cut
we could go to this shop and get the
ideas for our books but we are not
allowed to tell you where it is I've
only sold me - there's a whole series of
initiation programs that you have to go
through before you know the location of
the idea shop um no I mean I don't know
you know ideas don't arrive in that they
don't come like plop into your head you
know they all very very rarely it could
happen with a short story sometimes that
you can conceive of more or less the
whole thing you know
with the novel it's not like that you
know it's it's messy and clumsy and you
stagger towards the thing that you're
trying to make and you only half
understand what you're doing and
gradually you hope to understand it
better and better - by the time you
finish the book you feel that you're
offering people something that you've
come to know you know but it's a it's
it's such an inexact thing and it never
happens the same way twice in my
experience you know sometimes you have a
bit of a bit of a narrative sometimes
you have a character sometimes you have
an incident or two that that seemed to
be rich in potential you know Joseph
Heller used to say that with him it
always started with with with particular
sentences that he would imagine he would
come up with sentences and he knew that
that sentence would have a couple of
hundred more sentences that could flow
from that sentence you know and and I've
had that experience also but but but the
problem is it's never the same way twice
and that's what's frustrating about it
you know I think if you write another
kind of fiction if you
genre fiction you know where there is a
more structure and a formula and a kind
of repetitiveness even about it then
maybe in that in that world you can
actually do it the same way each time
but it's not been my experience and I
know thank you so Mon thank you all for
coming
copybook fair
they